let's say I have the number 905 905
point zero seven four so how could I
expand this out of what does this
actually represent so let's just think
about each of the place values here the
nine right over here this is in the
hundreds place this literally represents
nine hundreds so we could rewrite that
nine as nine hundreds or let me write it
two ways we could write it as nine
hundred which is the same thing as nine
times 100 now this is zero that's just
going to represent zero tens but zero
tens is still just zero so we don't have
to really worry about that it's not
adding any value to our expression or to
our number now we have this five this
five is in the ones place it literally
represents five ones or you could just
say it represents five now if we wanted
to write it as five ones we could say
well that's going to be five times one
so so far we've represented 905 900 plus
five or nine times 100 plus five times
one and you might say hey how do I know
whether I should multiply or add first I
do this addition before I do this
multiplication and I'll always remind
you order of operations in this scenario
you would do your multiplication before
you do your addition so you would
multiply your five times one and your
nine times 100 before adding these two
things together but let's move on
you have another zero this is zero is in
the tenths place this is telling us the
number of tenths we're going to have
this is zero ten so it's really not
adding much now we were not adding
anything now we go to the hut now we go
to the hundredths place the hundredths
place so this literally represents seven
hundredths so we could write this as
seven hundredths or seven times one
hundredths
so plus seven times 100 and then finally
we go to the thousandths place so we go
to the thousandths place and we have
four thousandths so that literally
represent
for over a thousand or four times a
thousand four times a thousandth notice
this is coming from the hundreds place
you have zero tens but I'll write the
tens place there just so you see it so
it's zero ten so I didn't even bother to
write that down then you have your ones
place you have five ones then you have
zero tenths so I didn't write that down
then you have seven hundredths seven
hundredths and then you have four
thousandths four thousandths so and we
are done we've written this out really
just understanding what this number
represents